everybody this is gary vaynerchuk and i
am the author of crush it
you know new media's redefining
everything you know I mean if you're in
the restaurant loving world as I am the
big you know think you look for was as a
God rating and now I don't look at that
and I look at my iphone and look at what
Yelp scored it right so and that's
community you know so this is going too
far outreach just wine I mean every
single word of mouth impact of business
which I don't know if you know this is
every business in the world is going to
be affected by this shift this is this
is printing press big this is not you
know some little fat this isn't about
Twitter this isn't about a facebook fan
page or tumblr this is game-changing you
know the internet that we know I know it
went back further nerds I'm sorry but
I'm talking about the one that we know
the one that AOL started sending CDs in
the mail is about 14 years old and if
you think about the impact globally
financially business-wise that it's had
its staggering and to be naive enough to
think that it's not going to have a way
bigger impact going forward I don't want
to think about what's gonna happen in
five years it's just a totally big ships
these are big waves and their constant
this is a hurricane this isn't a drizzle
and so I think it's had a big one on the
wine industry you know I know what wine
library TV has meant to wineries that
I've gotten good ratings or bad ratings
and when I can do something as one
individual with zero cost just sweat
equity and create a platform like wine
rbtv that has the same impact that
things like the wine spectator and
Robert Parker bad which about decades of
a head start and millions of millions of
dollars and tons of infrastructure that
needs to be paid attention to and
understood that it's replicated in
multiple platforms
you know I I think it's funny I think
there's this huge trend that everybody's
so excited to dis you know Parker and
spectator in 100 point scale but at the
end of the day if you really go back
prior to them coming along wine was this
big and I think that at some level it
made it a little bit more inclusive you
know people understand what a 99 means
in 100 point scale what a 81 means and
before you blame Parker and spectator
you should blame the retailers in the
wineries who've made them big you know
if I didn't put Robert Parker shelf
talkers on every wine in my store or
when I emailed out saying 95 points
Parker when he wouldn't mean anything
right so well obviously not just me I
mean everybody but you know so I think
that it's imperative for people to
understand that I think it had a lot of
value do I believe that community driven
stuff like Yelp is going to be important
sure I do that's why ball court calm and
why I'm relaunching it now and which is
actually I mean we probably just
relaunched it by the way which is
amazing you know so yeah I mean a big
misconception of wine library TV what I
do is people think I want to be the new
Parker or the new spectator I have no
interest in that I just want to build
wine self-esteem
yeah I mean you know what's funny is
that my dad had a liquor store we were
shoppers discount liquors that was the
store I grew up in wine was not a play
in my household my dad drank vodka and
cognac because he's a good russian boy
that's what we do so I first fell in
love with wine when I realize people
collected and so my reading began at
seventeen sixteen because I wanted to
know a lot about it because people
collected it that was my hook I was a
collector the actual loving of wine
started really happening at like 22 23
when you know it started going from
being a commodity to being home and I
really like this stuff this is
interesting look at these crazy flavors
like how the heck did that just tastes
like a racket wall like you know those
kind of things right so um there was one
specific amarone that I had a tasting
when I was 22 when I could really taste
the chocolate so much so I walked
outside and called my mom remember like
when cellphones were like this big and
you're like you know like like that I
called my mom and I was like mom it's
going to happen I can taste these things
I can't believe this but I just tasted
chocolate and this wine and that was
probably when I was like oh this is
really getting good I was just enjoying
it
yeah that's a great question i think you
know i turned 30 on november 14th 2005
and you know there is a one percent of
unhappiness you know like okay i want to
buy the new york jets and so that's
gonna cost a couple billion dollars am I
going to really make a couple billion
dollars selling just wine and the
realization was I could have I very much
feel like could have had big big things
happen i launched my library in 1997 but
the laws in this country and people
watching this video right now in boston
can't buy wine for me right so I want to
do something else and at the same token
as I was feeling this itch in november i
went to a tasting in december and
realized people did not have wine
self-esteem they wanted to drink the
same old stuff they wanted to be
jerk-offs to each other because they
thought they knew something cuz they
read it in the latest spectator I just
thought the wine culture had a lot of
opportunity to be much cooler and you
know there's so many places around the
world that I've traveled to where there
isn't this you know uptight aspect to
the wine industry it's much more part of
culture and data life and I I felt like
I was the kind of character I knew my
personality and my DNA and my hustle
could create this platform that not only
would be successful then by virtue of
that success would create a different
kind of culture so wasn't so much that I
was dissatisfied as if it was just I
wanted to change the game again you know
there was an amazing feeling for me when
i launched Wine Library calm in 97 was
one of the first wine shops to do so
less than a handful and it changed the
game it blew up my family business from
a couple million dollars a year to
openly you know 50 60 million dollar
your business I wanted to do that again
you know I want to be a pioneer it's
what I want to do and so that's what I
did with wine library TV
you know I if anything maybe it was a
little bit too aggressive you know I I
just I just emailed everybody was like
hey let's do this like you know check
out my show what can I do for you at the
same token I think I don't think of that
as a mistake I feel as though I was a
little bit more raw I think you know six
months later I was a little more
polished but I wasn't more selective
every was like why don't you get
selective don't hit up everybody hit up
the top tier you know you can't blanket
email everybody you know when people
talk about marketing I think that's
crazy I feel like wine library TV was
itsy-bitsy tiny in 2006 but if somebody
hit me up they'd be really happy to have
the relationship today and so you know
what just hit top hit up the top 500
Twitter people today that's insanity
that its lead ism so you know I promise
up and having a lot of hustle and and
and you know that's what I did I mean if
a top wine bloggers was upset that I was
hitting up everybody it you know that
might have been a mistake in some
people's eyes but not in mind and so i'm
sure i made a million mistakes i mean i
built a big business around me you know
it's not the most scalable thing at a
lot of people's opinions but to me I
understand kind of the vision that I see
going forward and I try to stay away
from mistakes the mistakes I make are
the opportunities I haven't taken like
big platform television things like that
I'm sure there's mistakes in my nose but
there's very few let's get really
obnoxious there's zero mistakes in my
yeses because normally my threshold for
a yes is first learning not necessarily
the results I need to know this you know
I've thought about be seeing companies
just because I've never been v seed even
though it's a stupid thing to do
financially for the learning process
there was one big moment that was the
day i was on Conan O'Brien show and
slate com wrote a huge profile on the
same day and that and that and this was
in August about seven so Twitter was
still a baby and that whole community we
all knew each other kinda sorta and so
it became like the only thing people
talked about on twitter watch Gary on
Conan which was really cool it was
really my I was really starting to fray
into the tech world the web two point O
world the social media world whatever
the heck you want to call it and it was
one of the first people to kind of make
it right oh my god he's in his office
talking about why and he's now on the
Conan O'Brien show and I went really
well on top of that so it was a big
moment was first time wine was getting
late night exposure on multiple levels
it was an interesting an important
moment both in the wine business end in
the tech space I would say that is the
one moment that really I can pinpoint
other than that I'm not very big on
analytics and metrics and paying
attention of traffic and did we go 23%
and this and that I know what I'm doing
is right there's no ounce of me of that
has any doubt and I work for myself so
there's no justifying it to the
dinosaurs that pits I my check so I puts
me in a very substantially good position
in a lot of ways plus I've done it
before I mean I was making lots and lots
of money thousands of dollars a week and
some baseball cards you know I've built
up a family business in the first year I
ran it from three to ten million in
sales I know what I'm doing there's an
when it comes to making money and
building brand it's just something I was
born with I'm not going to Pat myself on
the back this is just its DNA
I'm a marathon runner you know
capitalizing on something like that just
doesn't you know how did I with CIA you
know I got more exposure night lined in
a piece Alan did a piece you know got
lots of more Twitter followers people
cared more I mean there's a lot of
things that happened you know but at the
end of the day what I think is important
is that people have to understand it's a
marathon you know building a business
doesn't happen in six weeks there's no
shortcuts you know getting a Twitter
account isn't a magic potion you know
people like you know roll up on me
especially in 2008 I got a Twitter
account it was a great what do you want
cookie I mean it's a you know it's not
going to change your business but you
know at the same token the people that
think this stuff is silly and it's not
important are just trying to draw lines
in the sand because they don't want to
be a part of it and that's a huge
mistake because unless you're retiring
in next six to 12 months you better
understand what this is all about inside
and out
my vision is that I sell so many copies
a crush it that Harper Collins gets off
my back and I can wing these next nine
for the rest of my career it's not a
good answer
you can tell them they know exactly you
know the funny part is this what I love
about is I signed with Harper studios
it's a totally different model you know
there I got offered almost as much for
one book as these guys gave me for 10
but the Rebs share in the back end was
substantially more so they've changed
the model quite a bit and I'm betting on
myself right so you know obviously I
want to participate and win on the back
end so I I'm very hungry to see what I
can do with this book and I'm gonna work
really hard at it and I'm very confident
I know you guys are big time and there's
a lot of people going to watch this
video so if for the people that watch
this video if you leave with one thing
out of this video even though there's
much more important things being said
about life and happiness and making
money about just playing the game
perfectly in my opinion this is what I
want you to leave with when you go into
a wine shop not only if you remember
what you like or don't or know what you
like or don't no matter what it is or
you have no idea just like the question
was asked you have to try a wine from a
varietal you've never had before please
don't buy another Pinot Grigio another's
in another Pinot Noir a different kind
of chardonnay no tonight she known you
know rueda alberini oh you know these
are the things i want you to look for
you've got to try a wine from kejoro you
know from bond ol from you know at a
Baptist from Argentina so the answer is
this I can tell you right now you are a
wine expert if you spend two years and
in that window you never order the same
kind of wine and if you do that and then
you once you hit all the wines you can
kind of find Gruner Veltliner Rieslings
from Germany reasonings from Washington
State you know different places making
different grapes you're gonna be shocked
of what you know and how much you
understand your palate because everybody
who's watching this right now here's
what you're really doing you're only
drinking coke and sprite every meal and
you have no idea of root beer Hawaiian
Punch grape soda black cherry you have
no clue tomato juice pomegranate juice
you have no idea if you like those
because you're sticking to Pinot Grigio
and Pinot Noir please for me try
something new
there's two countries right now that I
think you can be very safe in finding
some really neat stuff one is South
Africa if you order a Chenin Blanc or
find a Chenin Blanc very crisp very
clean very aromatic great with shellfish
and light salads you can get them for
eight to twelve bucks all day long and
in red hands down the dominant country
and value in my opinion is Portugal you
know Portugal is just ripping I think
the quality out of Portugal for seven to
twelve dollars is staggering I actually
want to do a twenty20 investigation and
how much these people are getting paid
over there because I can't figure out
the math of how the lines can be so good
and they can deliver them for seven
bucks so from the douro the dow alentejo
these are places that really make some
great great portuguese wines
what your palate likes so the makers for
sure the pedigree is important right you
know this builder is good you know the
chef's good you know this car maker is
good you've got a reference point to
knowing if the wine is going to be good
but this is farming I don't care for the
best wine maker of all time if it rains
every day you're finished so that's also
very very important what I think is most
important when you first start learning
is understanding the grape varietals
understanding the difference between
Chenin Blanc and some young blanc and
riesling and pinot noir and pinot gris
and there's a lot there that will really
be the foundation of what you like
the real move like the date move is to
like Google's asked you know like asset
Eric grape varietals right and just like
ask for like you know do you need late
harvest Grenache from the banyule you
know totally like throw off the somme
with the mad skills but you've got like
only one move if you want to be a little
bit more authentic which I highly
recommend I think it's imperative to
name off three wines that you've had in
the past that you've liked and that's
the sommelier to go in a different
direction with varietal or from a
different country you know me and to
expand your palate I think you know
there's a romance with you know being on
a date of saying you know to your date
you know let's explore some new stuff
together kind of thing I like cabs but
what else would I like well you might
like to Matt because there's big tannins
a big fruit you know and so that would
always be something that would be my
go-to move
you know I think if we're living the
Google era right I mean I feel like you
learn so much more by reading good blogs
like the nog raphy or fermentation dr. V
know there's there's just too many good
resources from the blogosphere and from
forums and you know what I love about
corked is not only can you review the
wines but then people can comment on
those reviews so like creating threaded
conversations around wines i think is
very cool and so i'm excited about the
fact that i don't think people have to
spend $150 for a class or you know
necessarily buy a book now both are so
worthwhile classes there's that
engagement interaction books it's kind
of there with you can you know you know
I still think there's nice romance about
a book though I'm thrilled for Kindle or
e-reader or whatever you know however
you why I pro knock yourself out it's
all about the content but I think
there's so much free content out there
that I don't necessarily need to sit
here and recommend a source that's going
to hit somebody in the wallet save those
20 bones to buy a good bottle wine
yeah we were talking outside and you
know i was saying you'd be shocked what
happens between 15 and 25 the wine world
right now 25 to 40 bones you can drink
world-class stuff that you know you
start getting into the shot of the pop
world priorat world you start getting
into wine set you can't necessarily get
to under 15 and they're really
sensational really I feel like the
quality of a wine given the depressed
market and given the advances in farming
a 30-dollar wine today probably tasted
as good as most sixty to eighty dollar
wines a decade ago that's powerful I
mean you know it's powerful it's a very
good direction for the wine drinker and
I think it's very obvious and so if I
could say anything if you're into wine
you know you start looking seriously at
25 to 40 bones you can get some crazy
stuff
no you're gonna overpay that's all I got
nothing there I mean why do the month
clubs are fine listen I created one for
gary vaynerchuk and Wine Library TV
because I wanted to create one that was
legit I mean people getting ripped off a
painful value for fancy packaging and a
letter that says thank you you know so
you know no
I think that the best way to do that is
to find sources that you respect and
Trust whether that's one number TV or
another blogger or local wine merchant
you know that that's the only way he's
going to keep you is by giving you great
service sink don't buy that try this but
I really do think we're going to see an
explosion and things like worked I mean
that's why I'm so bullish on it and
launching it now I think yelp has
provided a platform that people
understand that community driven scoring
has value and I think that's going to
come to wine in a big way
I think Napa Valley you know hate being
so anti USA right I think Napa's
massively overvalued I think I think
Priya rat in Spain is overpriced the
wines there tend to get into that sixty
to eighty dollar range I think that
there's parts of Bordeaux that are
overrated i think the left bank
overshadowing the right bank meaning poo
yakin and you know the Medoc those kind
of wines same staff those kind of wines
tend to get more reputation than maybe a
saint emilion and palmer all i think
it's a mistake I think there's there's a
lot of places that get a barossa valley
I mean I like it but it's not insane so
I think there's a substantive tosca up I
should have started I mean I think Super
Tuscans in Tuscany can get very
overrated I mean so many of those wines
start at sixty seventy dollars a bottle
and I think that's insanity so you know
I think I think there's a lot I think
there's a lot especially when there's so
many underrated places like the Provence
and languid dock and and mclaren vale or
clare valley in australia i think it's
crazy okanagan in kanda you know baja
california mexico so there's it's
interesting
yellowtail gets blamed for something
that was happening also with Robert
Parker and Jay Miller's impact on
Australia let me explain what I mean by
that Robert Parker's the you know
gorilla in the room very important wine
critic and he started reading a lot of
Australian wines that were under twenty
dollars 92 93 94 points the Marquis
Philip stuff you know it's you know ball
buster from Tate I mean there was wines
again big scores under 20 bucks and so
consumers started saying well I'm gonna
spend 50 when I can spend 20 and I think
yellowtail came out at the same time had
this big marketing push became a huge
brand and create a scenario where people
blamed yellowtail for everybody thinking
Australia was a ten dollar price range
category so all the premium Australian
producers really got hurt in that period
but it was really because the Parker
scores and the economy was starting to
soften and Spain and Portugal were
coming on strong with eight dollar wines
I think was a perfect storm that
yellowtail gets blamed for you know so
young till is executed on something
that's always worked in the US which is
good marketing and a little bit of
sweetness you know they have a little
bit more sugar levels and those Ozzie
whines then and so people like that and
it's easy to drink and kudos to them
because they were very aggressively
marketing and they really got a lot of
support from some big retailers around a
country like Sam's and total wine I
thought they played that very smart
there was a lot of smartness to what
Deutsch did there and have a lot of
respect for the way they built the brand
I think the goodness proves that wine
can be cut you know you can still build
big brands and leveraging marketing and
pop culture I think the bad thing is is
that you know people fall in love with
in just drink that I'm not as mad about
I don't feel bad for the Australian
business people they're the ones who
relied on Parker in spectator never
built a real business in the first place
so I'm not so worried about them I'm
more worried about the consumer that
drinks a magnum of yellow tail shiraz
every night and I want them to try
different things
one thing Tony Terlato did it you know
you brought Corvo and Santa Margarita
into this country that's a quite a feat
kendall-jackson jess jackson was the
pipe in one of the first pioneers of
building a real big brand what he did
with KJ is monumental you know but
there's not a lot of innovation on the
retail side on the producer side Pete
you know everybody ripped up their
plants to plant Pinot Noir it's a lot of
chasing and and not a lot of innovating
you know it's kind of it's kind of
shocking it's probably why I was able to
do so well in that world not because I
was so good but more because of lack of
competition
my mom and my dad he'll punch me in the
face if I did that in there my parents
by far but if you want me to break out
of that for a second i would say that
I'm a storyteller I think my success is
going to be because I'm a great
storyteller and in that's how I build
brands I tell stories to the to the
world to me Walt Disney Vince McMahon
and the notorious b.i.g are also great
storytellers that I respect
my dad told me very early on your word
is bond right he said he said you know
it came at a good time is when I was
into wu-tang clan too so I've heard it
and in the hip-hop song so probably was
a little more powerful to me but the
fact matter was my dad told me you make
a commitment i became the buyer of the
store at 22 years old he said you make a
commitment no matter what happens you
eat that wine you made a commitment and
that is absolutely to this day the
reason i think i'm doing well in a lot
of ways because i think DNA wise i'm a
very a DD type of character and a lot
going on but because that principle has
been stuck in me it's helped me not have
egg on my face probably a lot of times
where it could have really hurt me and
that's a very substantial core of my
principal
an ethical dilemma um probably with wine
library TV I remember I was doing a
Cabernet Franc episode and I wanted have
a Cabernet Franc from every part of the
world and we only had one California
four or five of our California camp
honks were out of stock and the only one
we had was from a good friend of mine
Shawn Larkin who let me sleep in his
house once on a trip and I did the show
we opened up the wines and he's always
made great Cab Franc so I was very
confident going in that it wouldn't be
anything weird but they were never too
spectacular that I'd give it a hundred
or anything right and I didn't like it
and I you know he could think really
fast and even it was only two seconds I
just remember thinking man this is not
interesting this is not a place I want
to be sitting and I went on and pan the
wine and he really got pissed you know
phone call f-bombs fight me after school
the whole nine you know so it was a it
was a very difficult thing it was
interesting crossroads because nobody
knew that I'd stayed his house in 1996
you know it's a long time ago and so it
was tough it was disappointing for me
but you know what the best part is now
we're back right like he gets it so like
it's like it's cool you know I mean I
just think at the end of the day you
can't win in this new world by not being
one hundred percent transparent
your personal brand is your resume you
know if you think anybody's hiring off a
resume in three years you're out of your
God darn mind you know ninety percent
people I know Google you first anyway no
shot so yeah whether you like it or not
I'm just laughing at people that don't
think they're selling right you know the
hippie movement in in san francisco in
the tech space that sometimes busts my
chops that they're always selling to
they just don't realize it they're not
selling the way they think they're
selling in a different way but they're
not you know and what push comes to
shove if you're not selling you're going
to go out of business and and they
always sell out to the big corporations
so you know you know this hierarchy of
don't be a salesperson or don't promote
yourself you know i understand and being
too much is definitely a bad thing and
i'm at bolt at that at times I get it
but I'm just you know excited and and I
think that it's important to build a
personal brand because it's the only
thing you're gonna have your reputation
online and in a new business world is
pretty much the game and so you got to
be a good person because you can't hide
anything and more importantly you've got
to be out there at some level I mean if
you've ever left a comment on a blog or
if you create a profile page on any
public site you are a personal brand
your you may not be a big one you know
Timmy behind in accounting may have a
Facebook page that's publican and a
Twitter he you know tim is a personal
brand you may not be hustling for it but
I promise you Timmy if you want to be an
account at vaynermedia one day I'm
looking that up so you know it's a
platform that can allow you to do very
special things it's not something you
can run away from you know being you
know an introvert is not a negative you
know you don't have to be obnoxious and
over the top you can be yourself that's
just fine but to be naive to the world
we're moving towards where informations
at your fingertips and it's readily
available and everything you do is being
monitored you know you have a problem
with big brother you take that up with
the euro that you were born in you know
take that up with your parents or God or
the world but the fact I matter is
you're here
and you've got skates on and a hockey
stick and I don't want to hear you
crying about wanting to be a basketball
player and if that analogy doesn't make
sense I understand but the fact that
matter is this you know we're living in
a very connected transparent everybody
knows your business world and I think
you need to embrace that and harness it
not run away from it because really it's
the reality the marketplace
putting it out there right like you know
any junior level executives sit in
meetings and want to vomit all over the
place from what's being said and say oh
my god the senior management or the CEO
or my boss just doesn't get it the
ability for you to create a blog or to
tweet about your thoughts and I
understand you can get fired so you've
got to be smart I'm not telling you go
rogue here you know people get mad at me
when I say that I'm not telling people
grab guns and go into post offices I'm
just saying to you know this America
it's not Russia you know you have the
right to you know speak your mind you
know and so I obviously we've got to be
respectful to the rules of the company
that pays your bills and you can't get
fired and you don't want to go on an
employment but you know I think it's
very smart of you know somebody writing
I have an idea and just putting it out
there because once you put out your
smarts you've got a real shot and
vaynermedia charges you know tons of
money you know hefty hefty amount of
money a month consulting but I put a lot
of it out for free on Gary Vaynerchuk
calm the reason it works is because I
talk in theory there and what I have a
client we talk specifics and there's a
lot of nuances and navigation through
specifics and and that's kind of where
that's at
I just want people to who are watching
this you know obviously I understand the
profile people that would watch this to
understand that I and plenty of the
people that I respect are not in the
business of collecting a million Twitter
friends you know this isn't haha I'm not
here to you no joke around we're here to
build big businesses this is a platform
shift you know you've got to understand
we've been playing under the same rules
of society for a long time when it comes
to telling stories newspaper magazine
radio billboards you know television and
television way up here with other print
media that was quite important I mean
this is big anybody can be in the game I
mean just that's wild to me the fact
that you could become the authority
about foreign affairs online and not
spend a lot of money is staggering now
you have to have the chops you probably
spend a lot of money in kind your
college bills or you know learning it or
paid your dues but the most important
chocolate pier in America can make seven
million dollars a year right through
sponsorship and speaking engagements and
deals selling chocolate that person can
come out of the Internet in 24 months
for the grand total of five thousand
dollars and a crapload of hours and I
just don't think people can believe in
it because it wasn't true 36 months ago
and I understand why people don't
believe in it but I know it's true and
I'm excited for this shift because I
think a lot of people that have would
have never been able to be really happy
talking and conversating around the
thing they love most are going to be
making seventy nine thousand dollars a
year and maybe not a buck ten but 79 but
boy oh boy waking up at eleven o'clock
eating captain crunch you know hanging
out with their kids and then the people
that have the true talent listen I feel
like I'm gonna make billions from the
platform so you know it's just really a
big shift it's a game-changer in
business everybody will be affected by
it and the quicker you wrap your head
around instead of making fun of it
because you just don't want it to happen
you learn a little bit touch it a little
bit don't give up after three days oh
this is stupid and understand where it's
going because boy oh boy there was a lot
of chatter about how stupid amazon was
in nineteen ninety five and six when i
was doing my library calm all the same
conversations from my industry the wine
industry about how stupid Wine Library
calm was and how went to work and
shipping laws it worked and so did
amazon and so did the huffington post
and so are many many many other things
so it's reality it's only going to get
much bigger and stronger and it's kind
of like you know it's kind of like a
lion you know if you get a little lion
and you have it when it's like a couple
days old you can have it in your house
as a pet you just can't and when it's a
little bit older it gets to that weird
zone where it's kind of like bigger but
it's still kind of okay bigger than a
dog not too scary but eventually that
damn line is gonna eat you and if you
keep it in your house and I I think this
internet platform not Facebook about
Twitter not YouTube the platform of the
internet it's going to eat up every
other one and so you better pay
attention
you know it's a really endless right i
mean there's not that many people that
own a space right here's what I know
anybody that spends a good amount of
time in their computer and they think
about wine I've got a really good chance
of being the first thing they think
about and the fact that there's not a
beer version of that and a coffee
version I you know and going to the
thing I believe in the most I think T in
this country is gonna be monstrous when
probably five to nine years from now you
know boy oh boy if you start laying down
the foundation now owning that niche
owning the pockets of tea drinkers in
this country Starbucks is going to have
a 10 million dollar contract in front of
you in eight years if you pump out if I
switch to t library TV right now and ran
it a hard for five years straight and
did everything that I think about doing
there's not an ounce of my body that
doesn't think I can make 10 million
dollars a year in five years so that you
know i think that there's yoga and
gardening and you know sportscenter
where's the sports center of the web you
know there's a lot of stuff there's a
lot of a lot of niches MMA who's the MMA
personality online who's the person that
everybody who's the bill simmons the
sports got ESPN version for MMA online
that every single day I mean there's
money in that you know advertisers are
clamoring towards that sport and if you
are the internet voice there's big
dollars in that so i think that people
really follow their passion so i wrote
this book and really owned that space
because they loved it that passion
they'd spend the 18 hours a day in the
trenches that are needed to build this
business because this is a marathon you
know i didn't stress about capitalizing
on conan because conan was a little
piece in a much bigger game